think about it for a moment before you
put pen to paper okay
what's that prefix the front of Zed meet
again that's the argument right so when
I say I said he was 2.3 what I mean is
tell me tell me draw all of the complex
numbers whose argument is that number
they're 2.3 not just to help you
remember we're in radians right so the
most famous number when you do in Vedas
is PI radians
I'm sorry Kathleen PI radians and that
takes you to in degrees that's that's a
180 it's a straight angle okay so 2 pi/3
what's that in degrees 120 degrees so
you've got a picture in your mind
remember when you're on the UM on the
Ayodhya grant and when you're ready with
quadrants you start from the positive
real axis that's okay upon hijackers
diagrams that's already if but you know
here right and then you start to measure
your 120 degrees you want to pile on
three okay so it's going to come around
all the way over that way now Fozzie can
get hundred twenty something like this
is a knot
that'll be 90 in there and there's your
third is that make sense now when I go
ahead and draw this fit for curly draw
Mickey now as you can see looks like I'm
only going to need the one second
quarter
you can see that if I were to say put
you on any one of these spots right like
put you here or here or here or anywhere
else on there the arguments of all of
those complex numbers will be to learn
three times you agree with that except
for one
what happens here the Rd what's your
argument at the origin
hmm now tell me again what does argument
me was Ahmed made on the board it's the
direction you have to face in right
measuring from here's the positive real
axis that's where we begin and then you
turn okay now if you're measuring to be
bad right you're measuring from there
so what angle can you measure is it zero
is it pi is a two pi is it well you know
what you're kind of any of those angles
right now this is kind of a dilemma for
us because like what I need to be able
to say what my argument is in an
unambiguous way okay the only
unambiguous thing you could say is that
if you could just lycée any number there
that you can't say any of those numbers
is better than the rest so none of the
values can be set as the algorithm so in
fact there is no argument at the origin
okay so that's why I have a hollow
circle there indicating that every part
of this whole line this what's this
ain't going in 30 degrees which is PI on
there's real answers if we wear along
that by the way it's not an interval
because that's fixed at both ends it's
not online because that goes on forever
forever
what's this quarters it starts with an R
it's a rate so everywhere along this ray
satisfies this equation all the ideas
any way you like they're all 2 PI over 3
except for the origin does that make
sense
now this is a case where well yeah you
shouldn't really do this algebraically
at all right not smiling so you just
think about the geometry the Ray would
go on forever because no matter how far
away you are remember a complex number
is magnitude and direction of vectors
may change it's the same in your
language you your magnitude could be
anything you like so everywhere on there
is taken exactly it goes on forever in
that direction but it doesn't go on
forever in this direction so it's a race
halfway between the line and interval
which has not to fix ends or no if it
ends but
well how look at this right now one of
the tricky things in the entire
extension to got an extension one is
like this too when you get to some of
the higher areas is that sometimes
questions are just trying to intimidate
you into not training them because they
look like mathematicians love very
concise language but as a result you're
like what is happening but the first one
for 30 table is really quite easy think
about it right this said this said I'm
just going to replace is just a general
technique you can use I can always
replace that with X plus iy I haven't
violated the number I've just written it
in a different way okay so if I write
the imaginary part this is number three
of that but this time I'm going to write
x plus y my Y instead of this in okay is
X plus iy what do I got
minus one plus 3i apparently that's four
now when I have a look at this if all I
need to do is remember which is the
imaginary part which is the real part
okay you can see this number here is
real by definition it's real okay
there's other real stuff that's going on
in this whole complex number what else
is real the minus one is also real okay
so that leaves you with these two terms
these two terms okay they are the
imaginary components will the imaginary
part that imaginary part of this is just
the numbers without the eyes right so
there's a Y there and then there's a
plus 3 there that's just equal to four
right so you're like oh what's that it
okay this is the imaginary part of this
so of course that just means it's that
so I know how to do all that
Wow hooray everyone I can do extension
to okay wait let's move into that there
we go now I can okay so this it looks
intimidating right
this one looks intimidating - you're
gonna have to do some multiplication of
complex numbers here but you're gonna do
that arithmetic was the easy bit
right so have a go at those I'll give
you another minute or two and then I'll
show you four and five together